how you doing man
how you doing richard thanks for having
me on good good what can i do for you
bro
so i'll use my forum post as a kind of a
reference here um
so i'm 28 going on 29 i'll be 29 in
february um this is the whole dating
thing is the one part of my life that i
really just never put uh focus on i've
been really career focused for most of
my adult life and um that's paid off
like for my bank standpoint i'm fine i'd
probably make about half a million this
year
um should be doing closer to a million
next year the business developing really
well
now um looks wise i'm not very tall guy
five six i'm kind of a skinny nerd and
that that's always just been who i am i
dress in colored shirts and i like
dungeons and dragons i'll just go ahead
and admit to that right there okay
but i i lift i do jiu jitsu i actually
had a pretty extensive martial arts
career from 12 to 22 ish so a 10-year
martial arts career before and now i'm
in my late 20s um we have a really good
brazilian jiu jitsu school down here in
nashville uh renzo gracie nashville so
i've been training there with uh those
guys
um avid hiker i do a lot of hiking with
my dog i was just throwing her toy
because she's over here and she wants to
like she's a one-year-old rottweiler
puppy but
i have those two things down
the whole concept of game though that's
my weakest area i don't fully understand
this concept rich and i'm the type of
guy who um
i
some people think i'm autistic i i can't
understand simple things like if you
need to assemble furniture i can't do it
i will screw it up every single time i
have a five piece desk upstairs that's
still screwed up because i never
bothered to go back and fix it now for a
living
um i was about to say i do um a tax
strategy consultant here in the united
states um
do some really advanced stuff i have
some really good colleagues that help me
learn faster than i think a lot of
people do
so i work with a lot of seven-figure
earners some some under that as well but
i'm really starting to pursue the bigger
numbers um and that leaves my point uh
complex things are very easy for me so
like i can do i write these complex tax
plans using multiple corporations and i
add trust to the equation i'll layer all
these loopholes on top but i know how to
do all that stuff so you're asking me to
make women complex for you okay so we
can do that so what's not working for
you okay so here's my what i want to
know is what specific actions now that i
have some context here what specific
actions can i take every week to build
kind of a pipeline of potential plates
that's really what i want to do right
now rich because i haven't done this
very much at all what are you doing to
introduce women into your life right now
i don't know how to take step one that's
my problem like i can't get the square
one if i can get to talk to pretty girls
do you have a dating app on your phone
that you're swiping on i have a dating
app i i think for me unless i figured
out some way to make it a really
attractive profile it's just not worth
my time even sitting on the toilet i
play with it a little bit but the
matches i get they're not anywhere near
what i'm interested in i'd rather do i'd
rather just crack through the the social
anxiety i grew up with and and um
attack it head-on with like cold
approach uh nashville i live in franklin
nashville is the bachelorette capital of
the world
there's more so i want men to approach
them here than anywhere else so there's
no excuse for me not so first of all
you're in the one percent right yes i am
so moff and a few of the others are
organizing a meet up uh close to you in
february i assume you're going
yeah he literally mentioned on the
forums he was the one who told me to
come on here okay make sure you go make
sure you go so that you can see these
guys do it in real life right because
they've been doing it for a while
they're good at it
like you've got to get on the ice if you
want to score a goal right
so
let me make this complex for you put on
all your gear you get your skates your
sharp you know you're throwing your your
stick and everything else in your bag
and you put it all on you get on the ice
and then you start warming up and you're
doing what you do and you start taking
some shots on the net and at some point
one of them is going to get in right
you're not even playing the game right
you got to get on the ice and you got to
start playing the game
you know um that means that you're going
to have to make some cold approaches
you're going to have to talk to some
women that you know that you're
attracted to you're going to have to
start swiping on the apps you're gonna
need to optimize your
um
social profile so that you get good
results using dating apps because
most guys will just take a a couple of
bathroom selfies or some shitty
photographs that showed up somewhere on
somebody else's phone they'll put it on
a dating app
uh and then they got nothing to roll
with jaron um has a great example so if
you follow jaren on instagram um he has
a great um
optimized instagram for
providing social proof for the kind of
life that he leads um you want to be
interesting like i talked last week
about being captivating
and that's one of the biggest areas that
a lot of guys miss you said that you're
in accounting
we can call that like i'm an accountant
by trade but i really focus on tax
strategy which you can there's right
there's players
yeah so don't so don't tell women that
you're an accountant or that you deal
with strat like tax strategies or
something like that um you know we'll
come up with something else for you you
know in a moment but
like the thing is that you've got it
like you can do anything to women except
bore them
right so that's my problem rich like i
hear you say that a lot and i just maybe
i'm more interesting than i give myself
credit for i don't see like i have this
i'm sure you're interesting to yourself
to your friends to the d d crew to the
jiu jitsu like all that stuff you know
the guys at the office people like me i
get i think i get way too much credit i
don't know what i do to earn it but i
who very much respect me who are very
accomplished men so clearly so
about me so follow so follow jaren on
instagram so that's his handle right
there you know jared scott um see see
what he's doing because that's an ideal
format right um
you're gonna have to take some pictures
right like you're gonna have to signal
to the world that i'm interesting and i
do cool stuff so whether you're at the
dojo you're competing you're away with
the guys from the office doing a
learning event or a speaking event
whatever is it you're doing maybe
there's somebody's interesting there
like
you've got to um
show them that you're going to invite
them into something that's interesting
most guys don't even think about doing
that right that's just one layer of the
cake you know like
in into your to your porridge i've been
i've been working the instagram a little
more mostly just photos of nature and my
dog and [ __ ] like that but i'm sure
whatever you see on jaren's football is
going to give me some good ideas
if i build up an instagram that's worth
looking at that might give me a leg up
in the dating apps because a lot of them
connect to it it doesn't hurt it you
know it only helps because that's where
women's minds operate and you want to be
intimate with women you want to have a
good time you want to be spoiled for
choice right so you're just going to
open yourself up to more opportunities
and it's not like you're creating this
to get the girls this is this is your
online resume this is your this is your
footprint online showing people not just
the chicks but showing people that
daniel les is an interesting guy
right um so tell that story right like
it's storytelling okay um you want to
get great photography you're going to
have to hire a photographer you're going
to have to you know get a couple of
outfits going on are you in shape right
now your face looks like it's a little
bit heavy with some weight
a little bit i think i've slacked a
little bit in the last couple of weeks
because the holidays but i'm it's
gradually improving it's something that
i worked on all year and just had mental
barriers to break through and now it's
like okay i'm consistently doing the
resistance training consistently going
jiu jitsu getting out hiking more i had
an issue with my foot that was
preventing me from hiking which is my
form of exercise i got that fixed i'm
waiting away dude
what do i weigh i don't even know right
now last i was on the scale i was at jiu
jitsu uh my stepdaughter was like 210
yeah you can't
like you can't manage what you're not
measuring and 210 at five six is heavy
like i'm 250.
my shoulders are getting wider as i'm
building the muscle but no but i can
tell but i can tell on your face that
you're overweight right like like i'm
215 and i'm just under 6'3 right so
you're carrying a lot more weight and
you don't look like you're like a
bodybuilder like muscle so you got to
lower the weight
right
i mean
i'm not sure if you read my book
you have
yes all right so what am i saying that
about the online dating i mean if you're
short then you have to look smacks in
every other area right i'm like i know
that i'm not optimized in that area it's
just something gradually gets better so
as i'm working that i'm looking for okay
how can i kind of get the ice broken
here so as i get more and more into the
best version myself i've already got the
process i'm just getting better and
better i want to get some wins dan is
is what you want like you want to get
some wins with women and if you're like
you know rate yourself on a scale of 0
to 10 with 10 being the best version of
yourself like where are you right now
i'm at an 80. you think so
with where i am in business where i am
mentally
i'm very much up there
in the looks department
in the looks of oh just straight looks
because i mean you're overweight right
like by a hair and i'm not saying that
to follow myself i'm saying it because
like i came from like my gut sticking
out like
significantly
dude
dude stop stop stop stop stop you need
to take an honest
and honest assessment of your sexual
market value and if you're 210 at five
six you're overweight
okay like you need to get down around a
buck sixty
a buck sixty five six yeah
my famous friend my old roommate's about
five five pocket hercules he was about a
hundred and forty five hundred fifty
pounds he was ripped right like if you
can get down to about a buck's 100
seventy
you're in better shape than 210 like 210
you're fat right
if if you're short you've got to have
everything else lined up out of the way
because
a lot of women will dismiss you
immediately because of height
especially on a dating app you know if
they sense that you're not tall enough
they won't even give you the time of day
you could be making a million dollars a
year and if they're not down with it
it's like now the guy's too
too small they'd rather date an 80 000 a
year six foot two teacher
it's that much of a big deal because
i've heard i've heard this go back and
forth with different guys on this
channel and it sounds like you can't be
short and fat dude like if you're short
you have to like you have to look the
part you have to be dialed in like you
have to be solid there's no like wiggle
room at all with that whatsoever is what
you're saying right
okay
all right there's no hey you know just
like me for who i am i'm a nice guy i
make lots of money and i'm dope at
dnd and i hike well
no like the thing is just a way for me
to express how geeky i really am i
haven't played it in years but um i just
my lifestyle is very much i'm kind of
adventuring outdoorsy i like to freaking
[ __ ] just that's not that interesting
i'm not a nightlife guy i'm not a bar
guy just i'm i'm not in that kind of
better for fun
we do for fun again a lot of outdoorsy
stuff like i'll do a lot of hiking
because i moved to this area in the last
year i've spent a lot of time this year
just exploring it going to different
ones going to different places visiting
different trails different landmarks um
hanging out with different like kind of
groups around different jeep groups i
got into jeeps um different
so so
okay so here's so here's how you get
women interested in you it's like you
know you have to invite them in to do
something you know that's like
fascinating because women typically
don't have a lot going on in the world
like they literally
love going on you know adventures with
with guys you know you got a boat you
got a fast car you got a jeep you got a
jeep so it's like hey you know what my
jeep's all decked out we're gonna go do
an off-road thing um you know let's pack
something for lunch ask her to pack
something for lunch you know if she's in
your frame sort of thing and then just
take off for a few hours right like this
is this is after the first sniff test
like after you have a coffee or a drink
with her and you make sure she's not
psycho and you know you're not going to
take her for three hour drive and she
tries to kill you i can see myself doing
stuff like that because i do a lot of
off road even with the street tires i'm
going to throw a bunch of mods on next
year
getting to that sniff test i can't even
get to that part like i don't even know
step one if i get step one i can kind of
get something going well you have to
give her something interesting to want
to come out and do the sniff test right
so if you're using dating apps for
example
a great photograph would be you with a
bunch of guys uh you know like on your
jeeps all together
looking the part right hey why don't you
come out and you know hang out with us
like there's adventurous women that like
that like there's a lot of chicks that
drive jeeps right they don't they don't
take them off-roading they just like
drive them because they think they look
tough and they drive around with their
little pink wheels and
the wheel cover sort of thing but if
you've got yours done up and that's
something that you can do and you've got
it in your dating app and you show it
you know in your instagram then all of a
sudden now you've now you've become a
little more captivating you're not just
the guy that crunches numbers
right
so
there's a lot of positioning that you
got to get out of the way but most
importantly right now like the thing
that's going to make the biggest
difference is going to help you get over
the anxiety because right now if you're
making a lot of cold approaches at 210
pounds fat
you're going to get like you're going to
get shot down a lot more than if you're
like 16 170 pounds you know looking good
wait too because i've been lift i've
been dead lifting it like a hundred
because i was aiming for right around
200 because i thought you would weigh
more with the muscle because muscle
weighs more than fat does you lose the
fat you gain the muscle theoretically
the weight and i haven't moved that much
that's why i've been going awful looks
too much
i used to slouch like a total pair
until i started lifting then this
started to spread out but the love
panels are still receding okay stop stop
it stop it stop it dude like you're like
you're just like blah blah blah like
you're you're complicating your life and
justifying why well i can deadlift this
and i can do that doesn't matter do you
have six pack abs
oh no
not so 17.
keep losing the weight till you get the
six-pack abs
no chick cares what you can deadlift
well no i mean i just i i was aiming for
a higher weight is what i'm saying so i
need to start aiming lower on the weight
and just do it more frequently yeah well
like unless you want to impress dudes
you know with your deadlifts then you're
not going to be around checks that often
yeah i'm just saying i'm like aiming for
200 pounds like now i need to set the
bar away the hell lower that's part of
my problem too
60 bucks 70 is a lot better than 210.
okay
yeah so and um you know i got to move
because i got a lot of people that are
waiting to come on um but moth will be
on after the show with his after show um
so hop on that if you can and chop it up
with him and jaren a little bit or on
the on the community did you make a post
on the community
um yeah that that's that forum post is
what i was driving information i don't
think i've seen it yet did i did i
comment on it because i because i don't
recognize you okay
okay so i'll look for it after and i'll
throw some comments in for you but um
yeah you got some work to do which is
totally fine you know like like the
first step in unplugging is becoming
aware of your own [ __ ] the second
step is becoming aware of all the
[ __ ] that's around you right now and
you're not even at the first step
because you're bullshitting yourself
saying that you know i should be putting
on more weight or or 210 pounds is fine
for five foot six it's not i'm telling
you right now that's [ __ ] i didn't
know until now so now that i know that
immediately it shifted my mind said like
oh [ __ ]
way the [ __ ] to you i gotta raise the
bar on this
so
that's the link there for um moff stereo
show he'll be on after the show so you
just download the app it's on android
and ios you guys can chop it up it's
kind of like a podcast like conversation
sort sort of thing but um i'll take a
look for your post and i'll and i'll
give you some more feedback but that
right now is going to be the most
important thing because you start making
a lot of cold approaches you know the
way that you look right now you're going
to get discouraged right like you might
you might get some interest but you'll
get a lot more interest if you look the
part
right i also get clothes that fit you
too daniel like you know like the baggy
you know like heavyweight 210 like
powerlifter yeah this is taylormade it's
just some button that's all yeah like no
but it's got to look a lot better like
if i like i'll put on a fitted shirt i
just ordered some from maxwell's a
couple of months ago they're supposed to
be here this week so i'll put one on for
another show just to show you what a
proper fit fitted shirt's supposed to
look like you'll see the physique right
like you'll see the upper chest you'll
see the taper come in you'll see it over
your shoulders and your arms that's what
a nice shirt looks like right so a
proper finisher doesn't cost a lot of
money but right now it's because you're
overweight it doesn't look very good
okay and i back the good ones i know
exactly what i mean the pair sticks out
all right i'll i'll riff with moth after
this but thank you rich i appreciate it
all right bro thanks
all right
you